i saw headlines okay
i saw don king talking in all the media
saying oh i'm all good with mike tyson
man we've worked it all out and you know
what i thought when i heard that
i thought man that's great news i love
to hear it but i'll believe it when i
hear it from mike oh absolutely i have i
can't
afford to be angry anybody give that
energy away man
we're not going to be here that long you
know i want to give you energy to
something powerful that's going to come
back and return
so she did communicate with don king and
and uh
just everything yeah it was beautiful
dude i love it okay great beautiful
because that's what i realized um once
you start experiencing
love you have to experience forgiveness
self-forgiveness
and you go to hope you know i mean
lineage and forgiveness in different
parts of life and then you realize that
um
at the end of the day we're dead it's
over right
that's true man yeah
dude